président patriat vous avez parfaitement
raison
ce n'est pas seulement une personne
admirable
le professeur pâtit lâchement assassiné
qui a été visée c'est la république
ce sont ces valeurs de liberté d'égalité
de fraternité de laïcité la main de cet
acte odieux
on la connaît c'est celle de l'islamisme
politique de l'islamisme radical
keenan est pas à son premier forfait
monsieur présent patriat vous avez
encore raison
quand vous dites que la première des
réponses c'est l'unité de la république
et de la nation toute entière car les
ennemis de la république en d'abord pour
premier objectif de nous diviser de
faire prospérer tous les amalgames de
déchaîner la haine pour embrigader à
servir et finalement assassiné
on connaît leurs méthodes faire le
procès de la france faire le procès de
son histoire comme si elle avait en
rougir de ses principes fondateurs qui
sont à l'opposé des leurs voilà pourquoi
nous sommes leur cible et que ce soit
dit ici que se soit répétée ici comme
ailleurs partout dans le monde
en france on peut publier des
caricatures librement
on connaît aussi vous l'avez dit leur
levier leur mode opératoire des lieux de
culte des tournées des associations
paravents des réseaux
sociaux proactif comme les lâches ils
agissent dans l'ombre et bien qu'ils
sachent qu'ils trouveront toujours la
république en travers de leur chemin
le gouvernement sous l'autorité du
président république les ministres
principalement concernées sont à
l'action et à la manoeuvre ils n'ont
jamais cessé de l'être ils sont dans
l'action quotidienne encore ce jour le
conseil des ministres a procédé sur la
proposition du ministre de l'intérieur à
la dissolution de l'une de ces
associations
la semaine dernière une mosquée radicale
a été fermée depuis 2010 8 356 lieu de
radicalisation ont également été
interdits
j'ai décidé de renforcer les effectifs
de renseignement 100 postes vont être
créés dédié à la surveillance des
réseaux sociaux depuis le début du
quinquennat
mille deux cent cinquante postes
supplémentaires ont été affectés à la
dgsi vendredi dernier je me suis rendu à
bruxelles pour rencontrer le président
de la commission européenne et le
commissaire breton pour pousser les deux
règlements européens qui lutteront
contre l'apologie du terrorisme en ligne
et contre la praille et pour la
prohibition des réseaux et ne ses textes
vont aboutir très prochainement
enfin vous le savez monsieur le
président nous travaillons
d'arrache-pied au projet de loi de lutte
contre le séparatisme annoncé je le
rappelle à la haute assemblée par le
président de la république dès avant la
commission de l'acte de conflans sainte
honorine et je ne doute pas que le sénat
apportera à ce texte
des compléments très utile je vous
remercie
[Musique]